قالت مصادر رسميه تركيه للجزيره ان روسيا
تبذل جهودا لتلبيه مطالبه لها في شمال
سوريا كبديل عن العمليه العسكريه ويتمثلوا
اهم مطلب في انسحاب قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه من منبج وعين العرب وترفعت
بواقع 30 كلم عن الحدود التركيه وقال
تنقرا انها اعطت مهله زمنيه للقبولي
بشروطها في المقابل طلب الموسى لحن
الاكراد واشنطن بموقف اقوى ضد انقره
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هناك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات الى اين تسيروا اخر
مواقف الاطراف المعنيه بالتسعيدي على
الحدود التركيه السوريه من الطرح الداعي
لتراجع القوات الكرديه 30 كلم عن حدود
تركيا وكيف تتعامل القوى الكبرى المعنيه
بهذه الازمه مع مستجداتها وكيف ستتصرف في
حال انزلقت الامور نحو المواجهه وما هي
سيناريوهات الميدانيه التي تنتظر المنطقه
واي انعكاسات سياسيه لها بالنظر لتعقيدات
العلاقات التركيه الروسيه الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
قالت انقره ما عندها طرحه مطالبه واضحه
تتمثل في انسحاب قوات ما تعرف بسوريا
ديمقراطيه ل 30 كيلو مترا بعيدا عن الحدود
التركيه على ان تحل محلها اجهزه النظام
السوري والا فان البديله لن يكون سوى
تواغلا بريا يعيد تشكيل المشهد في المنطقه
وفرده واقع مغير فيها تبذل موسكو هنا
وهناك وتترد وتردد واشنطن مخاوفها من ان
يستفيد تنظيم الدوله من التصعيد القائم في
الاسنان تجدد القوات التركيه قصف مواقع ما
تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه شمال شرقي
سوريا وزاره الدفاع تركيا قالت انها حيدت
عددا من مسلح حزب العمال الكردستاني
ووحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه التي تعتبرها
انقره امتدادا مسلحا للحزب في سوريا
وافادت مصادره حاليا للجزيره مدفعيا تركيا
طالما واقع لما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في قرى بمحيط عين العرب
كوباني الحدوديه مع تركيا بريفي حلب كما
استهدفت المدفعيه التركيه المتميزه في
مناطق المعارضه الشماليه حلب مواقع قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه في محيط بلدتي تل رفعت
بريف حلب وفق المصادر ذاتها
الناطق باسم رئاسه التركيه ابراهيم قال ان
العمليه العسكريه التركيه البريه قد تبدا
في اي وقت وان ذلك يعتمد على تقييم
المراجع المعنيه وهكذا قال لنا ان تركيا
لم تستهدف حتى الان اي جنود امريكيين او
روس وان هدفها الوحيد هو وحدات وحمايه
الشعب الكرديه الموجوده في شمال سوريا
الى انقراض تطالب بان تكون وحدات وحمايه
الشعب الكرديه في مناطق تبعد 30 كلم عن
الحدود التركيه وان تتوقف عن محاوله
التسلل الى تركيا
في المقابله قال قائد ما تعرفه باسم قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه المظلوم عبد في حديثا
لوكاله رويترز ان قواتهم ما زالت تخشى بدا
هجوم البريا تركيا رغم التطمينات
الامريكيه وطلب عبدي واشنطن برساله
تحذيريه اقوى لتركيا بعد حجتها مزيدا من
تعزيزات العسكريه عند الحدود مع سوريا
وبشان التعاون مع النظام السوري قال عبدي
ان قواته لن تعتمد على الدفاعات الجويه
التابعه للنظام السوري الضعيفه النسبيه في
التصدي للضربات الجويه التركيه حسب وصفه
وكان جون كيربي مناسب الاتصالات في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي قال ان من حق تركيا
دفعه ما وصفه بالارهاب عن نفسها غير انه
اشار الى معارضه بلاده اي تحرك قد يؤثر
على مواصلات الحرب على تنظيم الدوله او
يوقع ضحايا بين المدنيين
للهجمات الارهابيه ان كان بالقرب من
حدودها او داخل البلاد ولها الحق في
الدفاع عن نفسها ومواطنها ضد الاعتداءات
ما قلناه ايضا هو اننا نريد ان نرى تخفيضا
للتصعيد ولا نريد ان نرى ايه اعمال قد
تؤدي اولا الى وقوع ضحايا اضافيين خاصه
المدنيين وثانيا لا نريد ان نرى اي فعل من
شانه الاضرار بجهودنا لمواصلات العمل مع
نظراءنا السوريين ضد تنظيم داعش والذي ما
يزال تهديدا حقيقيا داخل العراق وسوريا
وعلينا ان نواصل الضغط عليه
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من انقر الكاتب
هو المحلل السياسي محمد اجيت ومن موسكو
مدير مركز الدراسات التركيه الجديده في
موسكو ومن ميريلاند تشارس كابتشين عضو
مجلس الامن القوميه الامريكيه السابق
مرحبا بكم جميعا
ما هو المقبول تركيا في حاله تنفيذه لن
يتم الذهاب الى تنفيذ هذه العمليه البريه
وهل هناك مساحه مرنه يمكن لتركيا ان
تقبلها في اي طرح يطرح امامها
تركي بارك بالنسبه الى تركيا
فهذه المواجهه القتال ليس ضد اكراد سوريا
الذي تعتبر الاداره الامريكيه ايضا بين
المنظمات الارهابيه اذا
قادت وحدات حمايه شعب تركيا
ما فهمته من عدد من المصادر الامنيه
بلاي ستيشن
النهائي متوقع لاطلاق هي عمليه بريه
وبحسب ما فهمته فان النقاشات بين الولايات
المتحده
والمسؤولين الروس اذا سوف يتاخذ هذا
القرار النهائي من اجل بدء العمل البريه
او
التراجع عنها
بالنسبه الى تركيا ففي العام 2019
فان كلا من روسيا والولايات المتحده قبلت
بشروط تركيا من اجل دفعي بعناصر وحده
حمايه الشعب تركيا 30 كيلو مترا بعيدا عن
الحدود التركيه لانها تشكل تهديدا حقيقيا
للحدود التركيه وكذلك
لسياده تركيا على اراضيها مؤخرا
همم صعب تايلوس
في وسطي العاص في وسط المدينه اسطنبول وهي
قد ارتكابتها واحده حمايه الشعب بتركيا
اما الاسبوع الماضي ففي منطقه غازي عن
تابعه للحدود فان طفلا في الخامسه من عمره
ومدرسا
اذا الموضوع له تداعيات من ناحيه عدم
تنفيذ اتفاق سوشي كما تنظر اليه همم ينظر
اليها الجانب التركي انقل هذه النقطه همم
السيد يوري في موسكو همم ايضا هناك حديث
للمتحدث باسم الكرمله تحدث عن وجود تفاصيل
دقيقه في نهج تطبيق اتفاق سوت شيء بين
تركيا وروسيا همم بالتالي يفهم من هذا
الكلام بان هناك تعقيدات في عمليه تطبيق
اتفاق سوتشي 2019 هل لك ان تحدث عن طبيعه
هذه التعقيدات الدقيقه
من تركيا منذ بعض الاسابيع عندما
بدات الضربات الجويه
من العمليه كان هناك بعض التضاربات
يتضارب مع ما سمعناه
سمعناه اليوم من المتحدث باسم الرئيس
التركي
واعتقد ان هذا كان ابراهيم كريم انه ممثل
ان الممثل الرئيسي للرئيس اردوغان قال ان
العمليه العسكريه في سوريا وفي العراق هو
امر متفق عليه مع سوري مع روسيا وهذا شيء
مثير للتساؤل اذا كان هناك في المعلومات
هذا يع- وفي نفس الوقت يقول عن فقد اذا
كان هناك اتفاقات اذن يعني انه لا يوجد اي
تضارب امم افهم منك اكثر اذا هناك طرح
روسي لتنفيذ اتفاق سوشي ام ان هناك سيد
يوري طرح روسي جديد تحاول روسيا وضعه امام
الاتراك لتجنب الذهاب للعمليه
الروسي في سوريا اصبح اقل بكثير بعد
العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا
الكثير من القوات
روسيه خرجت واخرجت من هناك لذلك
روسيا مهتم بهذه العمليه العسكريه لان
هناك اهداف
مش همم
هناك هدف
هو قسم العلاقات او شرق العلاقات بين
تركيا وامريكا لاننا نعلم ان القوات
الكرديه الغير شرعيه هي تحت الاداره
الامريكيه لذلك روسيا التي ليس لديها قدره
على ان تسيطر على الشمال السوري هي ليست
ضد هذه العمليه العسكريه لذلك في الواقع
اعتقد ان
ليس هناك اي تضاربات او اختلافات عميقه
المشكله الوحيده
هل ستعود همم القوات التركيه للخروج من
هذه المنطقه ما يعني منطقه من 30 كيلو متر
حتى تركيا نفسها لا تعلم التفاصيل في هذا
في هذه المساله يعني
تستمع الى هذه النقطه يبدو بان سيد يوري
يقول بان روسي ليس لها مصلحه في تلك
الوساطه التي قد تجنب مثل هذه العمليه
العسكريه البريه لتركيا في الشمال السوري
الشخص الذي ربما هي مصلحه امريكيه اكثر
ااا منها روسيه همم اين همم واشنطن بعيدا
عن التحذرات او التطوينات التي تبثها
للطرف التركي او الكردي
متى تحدث
باسمي الاداره الامريكيه فان تركيا عانت
بسبب الاعتداء في اسطنبول وكما قال زميلنا
هناك رابط بين وحده حمايه شعب تركيا
التي
قد تقترب من اشياء
سوف يكون هناك تبيعات سيكون هناك
ديمقراطيه على عدد من السجون سيكون هناك
صعوبه
ومطبات في العلاقات بين تركيا وعدد من
الاطراف
بينما همم لديه علاقه جيده الان مع بوتين
وهذا يبقي المج مفتوحه لنقاش حول موضوع
اوكرانيا قد نشهدوا ايضا بسبب هذه العمليه
هوسات جديده من اللاجئين
والسؤالنا هل هناك طريقه اخرى
لمعالجه مخاوف تركيا مثلا الضغط من روسيا
والولايات المتحده لحاملي قوات سوريا
ديمقراطيه ووحدات حمايه الشعب التركيه
بقيادتها الخروج من هذه المنطقه على امل
ان تتمكن ديبلوماسيه من تجنيدنا تبيعات
هذا الاشتياح التركي العسكري المحتمل
شروط التركيه
لتجنب الذهاب لهذه العمليه غير الانسحاب
من هذه المناطق الثلاثه من بشجره وعين
العرب كوباني همم وايضا هناك مطلب بان
تكون القوات حرس الحدود ليه النظام السوري
هي من تؤمن هذه المنطقه هنا نريد ان نفهم
منك النظام السوري الحاضر الغائب على
الحدود الشماليه السوريه مع تركيا ما
طبيعه العلاقه همم
مقبوله تركيا مع دمشق ضمن هذه المعادله
طبعا
تحاول تركيا ان تبني على علاقات جيده مع
النظام في دمشق ولكن من جهات اخرى فان
النظام الاسد
لا يمكنه ان يتصدى الانشطه الارهابيه في
شمال سوريا
حالث تركي ان شاهد اخرى
في سنوات الخمسه الاخيره ارجعت تركيا
ثلاث عمليات مختلفه في شمال سوريا
مع الولايات المتحده لم تنقطع
هناك حاجه لضمان الامن التركي لان انقره
ترى في ذلك مشكله
مؤثره كثيرا على سلامه اراضيهم متعدده من
السنوات فان القتال الذي حصل في سوريا هذه
الحرب التي شهدتها البلاد انتقلت الى شرق
تركيا
داخل الاراضي التركيه اذا هي مشكله قاتله
بنسبه الى امن تركيا
وسيادتها على ارضها وسلامه اراضيها
0 0
قرارا نهائيا فلاروسيا ولا الولايات
المتحده
ستتمكن من فنيها او حتى التصديلها
سيد ديوري اذا صممت تركيا على الذهاب الى
مثل هذه العمليه فلا احد سيافنيها عنها في
المقابل كما شرحت لنا بان روسيا ربما قد
لا تكون يعني معنيه كثيره بالعمل على
تجنيد شمال سوريا
ولكن هناك تحذيرات من ان مساحات اخرى قد
تكون هي مسرح لا منزلقات همم تؤثر على
الحاله الامنيه في مناطق تعني الطرف
الروسي همم يعني في سوريا الى اي درجه هذا
الامر قد يلعب دور همم يعني همم لدفع
روسيا للعمل من اجل عدم ذهب الامور باتجاه
التصعيد البري
[موسيقى]
ماين تحدي
روسيا ليس هناك الكثير من ما يمكن ان
تفعله لتضغط على تركيا لان الحكومه
التركيه والرئيس التركي يتحدثون عن ان
العمليه العسكريه سوف تحدث ولن يستطيع احد
من ايقاف تركيا
قامت بثلاث عمليات عسكريه ضخمه اذا لم
ننظر الى العمليات الاقل حده ولكني اتخيل
ان
دكتور تركيا
[موسيقى]
من سوريا لان هذا ايضا سوف يؤثر على الامن
التركي
لان سوريا الموحده
هي شيء يتطابق مع الاهتمامات والمصالح
التركيه لذلك تركيا تلعب لعبه خطيره لان
الحدود السوريات ساخنه جدا وهي عريضه جدا
وهذا شيء صعب ان نفهم لاي حد تركيا
مستوى التهديدات الامنيه والاضطراب الامني
الى مساحات روسيا معنيه فيها في سوريا
باختصار
فيديو
العلاقات
روسيا وسوريا صعب هي علاقات صعبه جدا
ان روسيا احيانا تحاول ان تستخدم تركيا
لعقاب النظام بشار الاسد وهذا حدث
الامارات عديده وهذا شيء يؤكد ان العلاقات
سيد بشار الاسد هي على علاقات صعبه جدا
انت الرؤوس هذه ليست احلام ورديه ليست
علاقات مبنيه بشكل جيد انها علاقات جدا
غريبه وبعيده عن المثاليه لانها ليست
العلاقات التي كانت في الاعوام في 2017 او
2019 وايضا الاثر الايراني في سوريا اعتقد
ان هذا شيء لا يرضي روسيا ولا يرضي تركيا
لذلك بين تركيا وروسيا هناك اهتمامات
مشتركه
هل من طرح امريكي لتجنب عمليه بريه يعني
هل من تصور او مقترح
حقيقي سيوضع على طاوله غير المقترح الروسي
الذي يجري الحديث عنه في الكواليس بانه
مقدم من اجل تفعيل اتفاق صوت في 2019
باكس
الى
قرار الولايات المتحده الدخول في شراكه مع
الاكراد في سوريا من اجل تصدي لتنظيم
الدوله بذلت جهود من اجل تصميمه تركيا
بشان تحذيرات امريكيه الى الاكراد حول
ضروره
الاعتداء على تركيا اخراج حمايه شعب تركيا
من جيوب منبر كما سميت
صارت بين المواقع التركيه في عفرين واكثر
الى الشرق
ان يكون هناك طرق لاقناعي انقراض ان هناك
الشعب الى
الامام ولكن يجب ان ندرك ان سوريا
الشمال اذا اجتاحت تركيا اذا بدانا نرى
المزيد من المواجهات والقتال لا نعرف ماذا
افعله النظام السوري وستفعله روسيا وهم
اصلا منهمكون رؤساء لم تعد موجوده كما كان
من قبل لانها لديهم وجاد في اوكرانيا
وبالتالي انا ارى انه من الممكن ان يكون
هذا الاشياء التركيه الجديد يفتح الباب
على مصراعيه امام ما قد يستمر بقتال لا
ينتهي داخل سوريا شكرا لك من ميريلاند
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي السابق هو من
موسكويوري ما فيها شيء مدير مركز الدراسات
التركيه الجديده في موسكو ومن انقر الكاتب
والمحل الاساسيه
شكرا جزيلا لكم
نحن لا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء بحول الله
[موسيقى]